this is ocean gym oh yeah how's that
season finale working out for you
uh yeah yeah you know who the fuck is I
was only off by about oh I have to last
when I was like really this is the
season
oh oh that's all I said I said I think
so no no no no yeah I was on according
to Amazon this is the end of their first
volume so you have to pay more for the
other volumes and say you know Holly do
things you in a few days when this go up
we're gonna get so many comments yes as
so many people keep coming back and say
oh my god you're wrong about this your
is the worst um was we gonna say ah okay
that's really that's how we opened up
there's like this episode with like so
much shit going on it's just like I
wasn't the end of season 1 alley nothing
happens
my thing is it would have kind of Tina
got around good that was it yeah um and
of course when we seek Rhonda would mean
Barry to like they said and if he dies I
don't really know her gonna continue the
show without got really dark I'm
assuming maybe he clauses way out baby
yeah I don't know how I killed bill or
something but no this is an episode
where um lacus was i agent here is chair
there we go
we're lapis goes oh it's yeah uh where
she goes and takes the ocean with her
and turns out she's trying to use it to
get to her home
yeah because her jewel is crack or gem
is cracked and Stevenson saw healing
powers and he licks her back and that
allows her to grow wings her mere eyes
go away and she flies away they have no
idea this is a good thing or a bad thing
um I love I love the ending with the UH
so she made it off planet I guess we'll
have to wait and see Tom Tom Tom yeah
that way that's me otherwise what's your
so agency there's always two a master
and an apprentice come to talk so I mean
it seems like she did genuinely want to
get off but we don't know what that's
gonna be for them and we all
so find out that the gems you know
they're all ten UK fans you can fix the
gems so I I'm gonna wear it up
oh my going I'm hitting that point where
I'm just like so what is up with the
crystal gems then like she just said she
wanted to go home see he fixes her she
goes home and maybe she'll come back
with an army of Martians and kill
everybody I thought like she's gonna
come back with just like this voyage UFO
or like right now I'm just looking at
this like yeah Chris and gems can look
like dicks no be canonically but no
because it sounds weird all the songs in
real life but because we don't know the
politics of their planet of the world or
anything we can't know what this is
gonna be part look baby but maybe
there's another way it maybe it's up to
somebody like Stephen maybe you're that
he is the bridge between worlds um but
uh oh my god the animation this one was
fucking gorgeous ah the others were like
I see a dollar so just seeing a covered
in also it's very the concept of taking
the ocean and building this tower to
reach the stars I thought that's that's
really unique yeah enter head coming out
of it and stuff and then creating sort
of these water doubles of everybody was
a fun idea great use of the soundtrack
to and I always feel like I'm listening
to Mario Cart sometimes the soundtrack
we don't do did it I was like 200 but
yeah the uh it just I don't know it just
seemed very easy to solve that problem
so I mean maybe it's all the ruse and
maybe lapis is evil as fuck but I um I
have my suspicions here yeah here's my
guess because they do not build her up
like a straight-up bad guy she's not
like this monster is looking thing or
creature like the other ones and they
say the gems get like corrupted stuff my
guess is well that was the other big
reveal we should mention yeah that the
gems gets corrupted and turned into
these monsters it's I'm kin like this
you would know but
medaka Madoka Magica kind of feel out of
this like anybody who's seen the show
maybe you know what I'm talking about
I'm getting this vibe all this
with the yeah well they were once gems
out of corrupted their these monsters
and we imprison them and and it you have
to fight them and then like hmm and you
don't quite know the good guy bad guy is
here at for a sounds I think it's one of
those things well I mean like with the
Stevens pan that would explain why
Stevens pet was human at first but you
know I think that told me it's well yeah
uh and I think that um I think the idea
is that like you know Steven could
possibly kind of bring the bag but maybe
they try before maybe couldn't get it me
that's why Rosa was like so unique
because she was like one of the few
people that could catch me but when they
were talking about our old not all jet
it's just I really wanted to say subtle
gems are equal some gems are more equal
than others like the conversation was
getting creepy for me rooms like well
some gems may be kind of evil so like
was she talking about when they're in
the monster phase or before that cuz
like is there a whole is this like some
sort of biblical thing where you got a
bunch of demon gems like running babies
like Sonic the Hedgehog there's a
Robotnik somewhere that's turning him
into bad gems are corrupting and we're
like more than range right like you
can't do the nine rings and corrupt them
into nah school uh you know do we don't
know but my guess is well there's
finally mythos to analyze well you know
we could actually start picking it apart
which is yeah but my guess is that um uh
your chicks gonna go to her planet stuff
that she was probably someone who was
like probably like lost and angry or
something like there's probably on like
the villains side even though like
there's goodness to her maybe she got
sort of like taunted awareness at least
she was looking up at the stars she
seemed to disappear up into the stars
obviously some words and they said yeah
and they said straight she said straight
up like yeah all the crystal gems all
those three ever care about is Earth and
I never cared for this place I'm like
well what does that mean what is free
Ami's they didn't come from Earth and we
know but I mean it was that a thinly
veiled threat like I would totally burn
this place to the ground if I could or I
think she saw away if I had to guess
like I said cuz
make her straight they she does seem
like a straight-up villain even the
voice is too kind sounding to be white
straight up evil that I think they're
gonna build up they're like you know
she's kind of like she maybe on the bed
you know the villain side but she's
probably like you know like she could be
turned good or maybe like just the
villain head something if she D like you
know insert tragic backstory here that
could turn into good because I think
they designed her too nice and they gave
her two nice boys to be like okay this
is just a Bellis they're going the cupid
ugly round but yeah the the character
design is very play over the way she
left I mean she seemed very appreciative
and like yeah okay bye and I mean she
seemed very lost so I think that's it
that's all it takes what I don't know I
don't know Adam I think she has a
connection to some sort of other baddies
um I'm just saying something's fishy and
Jimtown hmm but yeah it's uh and I think
we get there I mean we already saw
something in the early episodes like
come down and tried to like attack them
in the camera what way was that like the
some of the I know forgetting I don't
know but something was trying to attack
me kept wearing amethyst habit oh but
yeah it's one of those things were it's
like that's my guess is that she's
connected with something or someone
that's really bad and but she yourself
it's not really bad she's sort of like
in between and then maybe in the end
she'll turn good or something or not or
major just died or maybe you should turn
evil who knows but I think she's served
like that in-between thing uh I think
Joel should have gone to the invention
exchange to come up with a way to like
replace this is the water creator what
do you think Matt what do you think sirs
um he is getting funnier and funnier I
never thought he was bad Donnie I had so
little I recognized his voice more what
he's in that panic mode Oh like what he
does that I saw me recognize it as Joel
light from mst3k well there is a
bullhorn we both go do something yeah
semana santa big do something uh yeah
probably did a good job sort of
explaining you know giving us more but
not explaining everything leaving just
enough so you're like wait wait what
about these questions and these
questions and stuff so I really like
that I likes it just gorgeous animation
on this one oh this was a good one lots
of reveals yeah but but again not now
the losses of funding - yes and we do
find out much more about like the gems
of the corruption and stuff like that oh
they can be turned and everything which
is fine I didn't need a linear story but
at some point I started to need some
pieces to fall in the place yeah I feel
I got it so yeah no more complaints at
least I did you know this satisfied me
you could probably have a few filler
episodes after this is I'd be fine yeah
that does price it's like okay I have
some concept of what's going on or at
least the mystery yeah uh so that'd be
my guess at the probably have like just
a goofy episode with like just the
tiniest reveals even that uh but no good
episode uh good reveals and great
animation and a good storytelling good
visuals uh you know with the ocean kind
of castle there and no complaints no
complaints yeah and definitely um it's
deafening with her with Connie putting
the glasses back on and stuff I'm just
like you know they did that because they
they have a look they have a model they
probably have the toys I know it just
put it back on even though there's no
reason for her to still have focus on um
alright some people dig chicks with
collisions baby
um but yeah that's about it and we will
see you at the next one later